Shinzo Abe was gunned down against a
certain religious organization
unemployed 41 year old man has said he
carried out the killing using a homemade
gun
[Music]
on July 8 2022 Shinzo Abe Japan's
longest serving prime minister was
assassinated in broad daylight hatred
for world leaders is not surprising
regardless of which side you choose it
and how accommodating you are someone
isn't going to despise you which is
completely fine diversity in thought and
debates are the key factors pushing
forward Humanity but the problem is that
when enough people despise you you start
getting some lunatics who end up pushing
things way too far this is why
government leaders get thousands of
death threats on an annual basis
President George W bush for example
received it 3 000 threats every year and
that President Barack Obama received as
much as two to five times that and since
1865 there have been attempts on the
lives of one of every four presidents
and the successful assassination of one
of every five the despite these Grim
statistics it does seem like
assassinations have been reduced in
recent history thanks to better
technology and security procedures that
spent 40 years since the U.S president
was shot and at nearly 60 years since
the U.S president was assassinated these
statistics were even better for Japan
who hadn't seen an assassination since
1936 but unfortunately Japan's
statistics were just reset and the worst
part is that the assassination may have
been prevented with some extra security
measures in place so here's exactly how
Japan's former prime minister Shinzo Abe
was assassinated
foreign
of July 8th 2022 started off just like
any other day for Shinzo Abe though he
was retired having stepped down from
being prime minister in late 2020 due to
health concerns Abe was still a leading
Voice Within Japan's political
environment he regularly helped his
colleagues campaign it and secure their
own spots within the political hierarchy
on this particular day Abe was scheduled
to campaign for sanjiro Matsuyama who
was running for the house of counselors
however this event was canceled at the
last second due to allegations growing
that Matsuyama was corrupt with the
event canceled Abe could have taken the
day off but he was already prepared to
give a speech and interact with the
public so he rescheduled the campaign
for kaisato instead Sato was an ldp
counselor running for re-election and he
was holding an event in Nara prefecture
this event was heavily marketed on
social media and it through word of
mouth but due to the last minute change
the general public wasn't even aware
that Abe would show up at this event you
would think that this would have
provided a with additional safety but
that doesn't seem to be the case anyway
the evening before the event Nara police
and sato's campaign staff would inspect
the area and they would find some red
flags one of the biggest concerns was
the amount of car and foot traffic that
was present in the road behind the event
nonetheless the security plan was
approved just a few hours before Abe
arrived with the green light from
security Sato would begin delivering his
speech at 11 10 AM Abe arrived
approximately nine minutes later and was
accompanied by a VIP protection officers
from both the Tokyo Metropolitan Police
Department and the Nara prefectual
police Abe began his speech 10 minutes
later at 11 29 am it appears that the
perpetrator was waiting for Abe to take
the stage because he would strike almost
instantaneously at 11 30 Ava declared
with enthusiasm instead of thinking
about why he cannot do it and that was
it the first shot had gone off everyone
was immediately alerted but no one was
quite sure what the sound even was the
security guards were extremely familiar
with how a firearm sounds but this
sounded nothing like a firearm it
sounded more like a firework or a tire
blowout everyone's eyes had frantically
searched for the source of the sound
including Abu turned around and the
second round of shots had been fired and
unlike the first round this round hit a
b in both the neck and the chest areas a
bit could feel the wind knocked out of
them as they took a few steps forward it
before he fell to his knees and
collapsed some of his security detail
immediately rushed to Abe While others
moved to detain a suspect who didn't
resist it turns out the suspect was
using a homemade firearm that was
capable of firing 6 Bullets at the same
time this is why the firing sound it
seemed so unfamiliar but while the sound
it may have been wonky it was a no less
lethal
foreign
die though he was actually conscious
shortly after and the bystanders would
attempt to help him they began CPR as
soon as possible and while I'm sure they
had good intentions medical experts
think that this only made things worse
generally the rule is to start CPR as
soon as you realize that someone has no
pulls and is not breathing but the wound
significantly complicated the situation
according to one paramedic performing
CPR on a penetrated heart would simply
increase chest trauma slash bleeding
speaking of paramedics paramedics would
arrive on scene in just seven minutes
after the incident at 11 37 am and ended
they would take over four minutes after
that at 11 41 am in an ambulance and a
doctor would arrive on scene but
unfortunately Abe had already lost
Consciousness by this point Abit would
be loaded into the ambulance before
being transported to a local hospital on
a helicopter within 50 minutes of being
shot by the time he arrived at the
hospital though he didn't know Vital
Signs likely due to cardiopulmonary
arrest over the next four hours doctors
would administer 100 units of blood
transfusions but none of this was enough
to revive Abe at 4 55 PM Abe's wife Aoki
arrived at the hospital and just eight
minutes later at 503 PM Shinto a was
pronounced dead at age 67. from there a
full police autopsy was performed which
confirmed that Abe had been killed by a
bullet damaging an artery under his
collarbone Japan would go on to host a
state-sponsored funeral which turned out
to be one of the most controversial
events of this entire Saga this was
Japan's first aid funeral since 1967 and
it came with a hefty price tag of 11.5
million dollars and given that Japan is
already undergoing an economic crisis
and an energy crisis it's not surprising
that many people did not want to spend
money on this funeral but to be honest I
doubt that the objections were strictly
objective as there's no doubt that
politics and especially the unification
Church played a role in this opposition
Abe had a deep ties with the unification
Church which once of Japan used as a
cult and by sponsoring Abe's funeral
many felt that the state was indirectly
supporting the church one of the most
notable opponents to the funeral seems
to be Japan's royal family who did not
attend a funeral many world leaders did
attend a funeral though including Kamala
Harris Narendra Modi Anthony Albanese
and Han daksu and with that the chapter
of Japan's longest serving prime
minister was over but all of this still
leaves one question unanswered why
foreign
was an extremely controversial
politician his demise was ironically and
not due to his political views but
rather his personal views and
specifically his connection to the
unification Church use here the
perpetrator tetsuya yamagami felt that
the unification church had robbed his
family of everything he felt that
eliminating Shinzo Abe was his form of
um community service to prevent more
families from going through the same
pain yamagami's hatred for the church
started at a very young age while
yamagami was born to affluent parents
who owned a construction business his
life would be turned on Heels when his
father took his own life when yamagami
was just four years old this left his
mother with the responsibility of taking
care of the business and raising the
children his mother was not emotionally
ready to handle this so she thought
Solas in the unification church when
yamagami was 11 years old over the next
seven years yamagami's mother would
essentially hand over their family's
entire world to the church she gave the
church 720 thousand dollars a piece of
land she hadn't heard it from her father
and the house that she and her children
lived in shortly after this she would
declare bankruptcy in 2002. by the time
yamagami grew up his family had gone
from being affluent to being bankrupt
and there was only one person yamagame
blamed the unification Church yamagami
would join the Japanese Marine Force
around the same time that his mother
declared bankruptcy but things didn't
get better they only got worse in fact
things got so bad at that in 2005
yamagami's Uncle contemplated taking his
own life so that his sister yamagami's
mother could get their life insurance
money fortunately he wouldn't do it but
someone else would it yamagami's brother
yamagami's brother had already struggled
with cancer for a long time and now he
couldn't afford his medical treatment
either so he decided to end it and it
was at this moment that yamagami knew
that he was going to exact his revenge
he made it his life's mission to take
down the unification in church and
posted things like I'm willing to die to
liberate every person involved in the
unification Church Abe wasn't yamagami's
first Target though for years he was
targeting high-ranking members of the
church such as hak Jahan Moon who is the
leader of the church at one point
yamagami was even targeting the entire
Moon family but he knew that this was
unrealistic so he shifted his Focus onto
someone that would make international
headlines and attract the attention of
the entire world and this was of course
Shinzo Abe yamagami shared that EBA
wasn't originally an enemy of his though
he wasn't a fan either but when he
realized that Shinzo Abe was the
unification Church sympathizer who
wielded the most influence in the real
world his Target was clear he would send
a Manifesto to a journalist on July 7
2022 and the rest is history
foreign
critiques Japan has received is Howard
security detail responded to the noise
there was a full two and a half seconds
between the two shots which was likely
plenty of time to take action but
instead of lunging to cover Abe it
appears that they didn't exactly know
what was happening or what to do this
has resulted in many blaming Abe
security for his death and there
definitely is some truth to this if this
was the American Secret Service they
probably would have had a much better
shot at the protecting ape just take a
look at how they protect Donald Trump
after a noise back clearly wasn't even a
firearm
thank you
[Applause]
the key thing to note though is that as
sad as it is the U.S is it used to gun
violence not to mention citizens are
able to legally own firearms and six U.S
presidents have already been shot by one
so looking out for this is at the top of
the secret service's Minds the same
however cannot be said about Japan who
has extremely strict loss running
firearms in all of 2021 for example only
one person was killed by gunbones across
all of Japan during the same time period
the US experienced over 45
000 deaths I think you can see why air
security was likely caught off guard we
should also note that they weren't even
protecting the current prime minister
they were protecting a former prime
minister who had already been retired
for nearly two years so you would think
that this would further reduce the
chances of something like this taking
place but unfortunately not while Shinzo
Abe May no longer be with us there's no
question that his impact is here to stay
according to his supporters Abe was a
ruthless pragmatist who would aimed to
build a strong Japan through economics
according to his haters Abe was a fierce
Nationalist and historical revisionist
who only cared about increasing his own
power but regardless of which side
you're on at I think we can all agree
that this is a tragedy that we don't
want to see repeated in any country were
you aware of this terrible tragedy
comment that down below also drop a like
if you hope that Abe rest in peace and
of course consider checking out our
Discord Community to suggest future
video ideas and to consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered
but until then I'm Ari and I'll see you
guys on the next one